à l'occasion de la sortie du globe
spécial mode et en coédition avec
georges marc benamou voici bain de
minuit numéro 11
plus chic que moi tu meurs
on
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
et
où
[Musique]
et
sir combescot bonsoir alors tu es
critique à l'express oui enfin bon on
appelle ça comme ça oui je fais un petit
peu de critiques sur la musique
symphonique et puis sur le ballet suite
une nouvelle terre avant moi j'ai connu
à l'époque de jean françois kahn va lui
mange et mêmes de fondations nouvelles
littéraires avec tesson et tu es resté
quand car est arrivé et je suis reste
naturellement mais quand il ya eu la
vente que ce qui s'est passé là-bas je
suis partie non parce que tu sais il ya
une âme a été vendue avec les mains en
moi j'étais sur les listes noires
j'étais un peu trop peu trop à droite
pour les luttes des signes le critique
du canard enchaîné est un copain -
saint-gobain qui te ressemble beaucoup
non non non pas du tout non non c'est un
être beaucoup plus utile que moi
beaucoup plus payet mai
voilà déjà dans l'ensemble j'ai été très
intéressé par ses deux premiers livres
parce que sa part les droits le premier
c'était louis ii de bavière un deuxième
et qu'ils le deuxième s'appelait c'était
un livre qui s'appelle les chevaliers
crépuscule de chez lattès et c'était le
roi de sicile à cette théorie c'était
une biographie enfin une première
esquisse d'une biographie sur frédéric
ii dont on vient d'ailleurs de publier
un très beau livre chez gallimard qui
l'ol staufen feuille de route en fin de
compte on revit ce qui est à mon sens le
plus beau livre de la vie en ce moment
alors les funérailles de la sardine
c'était il ya un an un premier rail de
la sardine c'était exactement il ya un
an puisque le prix est ici ça a été
donné aujourd'hui et c'est incroyable
parce que dans ton bouquin y avait un
personnage qui s'appelait lorenzo de
medici sans plus oui qui s'appelle
lorenzo de medici le secret destiné ça
m'était complètement prédestiné
d'ailleurs je l'avais écrit pour sa
lente et une passion plus ou moins
secrètes la danse aux amis ça on va pas
en parler ce soir je vous parle on en
est venus pour acheter un cri d'alarmé
beaucoup plus important que le bébé
phoque qu'on égorge c'est la mort du
tulle haye le tulle fous l'camp
aïe et alors quand tu le fout le camp
c'est absolument comme le subjonctif ces
derniers remparts d'utilisation tu
penses que l'occident s'écroule avec le
tube absolument avec la perte du tulle
le tulle nylon c'est un peu comme c'est
un peu comme le bas nylon sans couture
pour les jolies mollet l'espace a été la
fin des
des belles jambes et bien le tulle
aujourd'hui nylon cgt que quelque chose
s'en va quelque chose de notre
civilisation est en train de périr et ça
j'aimerais le dire car toutes les
grandes cassandre qu'il faut les traiter
de décomposition n'ont jamais parlé de
ce problème essentiel à notre
civilisation le tulle le tulle
c'est en partie la danse et s'il n'y a
pas un vrai tu l'on ne peut plus dense
et des grands ballets classiques parce
que le tulle fait tout le tulle c'est le
nuage de la cl site c'est la brume
derrière le décor c'est le nuage que
poursuit un prince un puzzle fils au
bord d'un lac
essayant d'attraper un signe de lui
faire son affaire
c'est ça le tulle toute petite femme
croupionnade alors aujourd'hui au groupe
young en lui donnant du nylon et ce
n'est pas possible voilà ne se
fabriquent plus je crains que de moins
en moins jeunes se fabrique est alors
naturellement on voit même la
répercussion sur les grands couturiers
même chez les grandes costumière car
karine ce cas par exemple à est parti à
la retraite parce que le tulle foutel
quand on ne sait plus coupés dans le
tulle on ne biaise plus dans le tulle
c'est atroce est ce qu'on peut faire ce
qu'il faut faire un saut et stu moi je
pense qu'il faut faire et ce véhicule il
faut prendre le tulle comme un symbole
d'une croisade pour la sauvegarde du
grand ballet romantique et d'un art de
vivre que ça peut qu'il va du champagne
perrier d'ailleurs est-ce que ça peut
intercepter un berger ça peut intéresser
naturellement qu'à vergès à l'intérêt au
premier degré la croix ça l'intéresse au
premier de droit ce sont des gens qui
font des tutus l'île saint laurent a
fait l'étude disent ils
a fait tous les plus beaux costumes de
théâtre et aujourd'hui où peut-il
trouver du tulle c'est très difficile
que ça peut intéresser jacques lang a
pour porter un tutu jack lang non je ne
pense pas encore que bon il en fait
parfois hilal est ce qu'on était prêt à
signer une pétition pour le tulle jeu si
toutes les pétitions pour le tulle
aucune contre pour le bébé femmes et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de finale
andy tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus